The school of AI that works on cognitive architectures makes sort of
fundamental assumptions about the nature of cognitive agents.
First, that cognitive agents are goal oriented, or goal directed.
They have goals and they take actions in the pursuit of those goals.
Second, that these cognitive agents live in a rich, complex,
dynamic environments. Third, this cognitive agent used knowledge of the world in
order to pursue their goals in this rich complex dynamic environments. Fourth,
that this knowledge is particular abstraction that captures the important things
about the world that the level of abstraction and removes all the details. And
at that level of abstraction, knowledge is captured in the form of symbols.
Fifth, the cognitive agents are very flexible.
The behavior is dependent upon the environment. As environment changes, so
does the behavior. And sixth cognitive agents learn from their experiences.
They're constantly learning as they interact with the world.